my name is Audrey cook and I worked at
mass seventy-one years the day the Queen
come everybody was so excited
there was the lovely day because I loved
the royal family well I think everybody
does don't they they'd like to see what
she's got on you know and when it when
she was crowned I mean I was in work but
my mom and her sister went to London and
slept out all night just to see because
that's what they did years ago because
we didn't have television but there was
a picture place on the Farm Road and
they had it on there so we went there in
the evening to see it I think everybody
likes the Queen you know and the day she
came here well from the bottom to the
top everybody was excited we were all
tired after it because you know you get
excited don't you and you have to curtsy
and but it was really nice she's been
good for the country and I wouldn't like
to see without the Queen and I hope she
stays as long as she can she has been
good you know I wouldn't like to see
anybody else take over not yet anyway
but I don't think she will give up
anyway
do you things you give up no I don't
think she'll give up